Phylis can we go back to is it the year
2000 when you first were approached
about adapting Patricia Highsmith's book
the price of salt was a 2000 I was
actually approached in 1997 Wow okay so
it's longer than even we thought but
I've managed to track down the actual
the dates now and so I finished that
annotation probably mid 1997 the first
draft Wow okay the world was a
completely different place at that time
so many different things I know you
waited a very long time to finish or
even get to the idea of finishing the
film why did you hang on so long well I
I felt a particular attachment to this
project because for one thing it was the
first script that I was actually hired
to write and over the years had formed
quite a bond with Tessa Ross from film
four who financed the development of
this and with the various some producers
who were attached at various stages and
I'd known Patricia Highsmith's she was a
friend of mine over the last decade of
her life so there was a personal
emotional investment in this in the only
and only the way that your first film or
your first love has that you know I
think if I'd done it now and we'd waited
all those years I I might feel
differently but it will always have a
very special place in my emotional life
this film I understand from something
else I read about you that it was almost
at some point you were so tired of
waiting for it to happen that you felt
sick or you you you really needed to
just move on in life can you talk about
where you were at that time what year
was this yeah this um right around I
think it was around 2010 the rights to
the book lapsed
and so the project I thought was gone it
was dead my script was useless without a
producer who owned the rights to the
book and I did move on and it was about
a year later that I got a call from
Elizabeth Carlson who is the one of the
producers of Carole and with whom I'd
worked before on a movie called mrs.
Harris for HBO that I wrote and directed
and also Christine Vashon produced that
with Liz and she said you know I've got
the rights to the book let's make a
movie and I said no thank you
there's too much water under the bridge
it's too painful too many false starts
and stops and I'm tired of it go find
some nice young unsuspecting fresh
writer to give you a new take on it and
she wouldn't let it go
she and Tessa Ross it took them a year
to convince me to give it another go and
at this point of course I'm I'm over the
moon that they did but yeah it was it
was frightening to me the thought of
stepping back into the breach not only
because it had been a long and painful
process and sometimes quite joyous but
you know at the end of the day it wasn't
made so painful but I was also a very
different writer at that point in my
life and I had a concern that I would
not be able to step back into the very
particular point of view that comes from
being a young writer who has a take and
a point of view on a piece of material
that was absolutely crucial to its
success in if it was going to be made
that optimism that hope that
all of those things that inform what's
at the core of Carroll but once I came
back on I thought why why was I afraid
of course it's easy you know this
material so well by now that if someone
had asked me to set it in a circus you
know with with performing elephants as
Carolyn Torres I could have done it you
know and it would have been moving but
to get to me back to that um yes frankly
it took a lot you can talk about the
process of adapting a novel into a
screenplay the actual physical process
like what how you begin it you sit at
your computer and where do you write
well that's never changed the same thing
that happened with Carroll has happened
with all subsequent projects
I read the novel obsessively maybe four
or five six times just quickly make a
bunch of notes that I then never ever
refer to ever again I just write things
down it's a bit like rote memorization
maybe that you you you take this stuff
in maybe by osmosis and then I go away
and I do something else so I'll go to a
bunch of baseball games or own you know
watch TV or all I'll do go to Vegas
something for a few weeks and then I
come back and if I've got say ten weeks
to do something I'll use eight of them
in other ways I won't even think about
it and then I'll sit down and I'll write
from page one to the end very quickly
and without stopping without revising
and without shuffling scenes around
there's something about a structure for
me
arriving at how something begins and
ends provides a structural tool and
that's really the way music mostly is
opposed so I look at it that way and
then the revision is always the same if
something is wrong on page 46 you know
the previous 45 pages also have to be
adjusted and all the pages that follow
because one thing is off it sets
something off in another section I've
never been someone who's learned how to
do that thing that I always see with
famous screenwriters you know the cards
the the ability to take one scene here
and put it here in this it always seems
that's not my process it's got to all
work as a piece in one long act almost
how are you writing in some of the
subtext so much of the movie there are
things implied nothing's really said but
the audience gets a general feeling they
know how these characters either feel
about each other or where things are
going
how are you writing that in well um
subtext generated in probably two ways
one is if this topic of your scene is
why are you cheating on me
as it sometimes is say with harsh and
Carol you have them talk about anything
but that in a way and in a context so
harsh and Carol talking about their
marriage whilst Torres is in the other
room and overhearing things you do it in
that way you you go off point of a
conversation you have a conversation
about how difficult it is to repair the
damn plumbing or whatever but and you do
that in order to make your point very
clear which is dammit this is this is
wrong all of this is wrong and the other
way which is really a one of my favorite
ways is to just describe behavior in a
certain context so Carolyn Torres riding
in a car what is she looking at what is
she doing what is this what's what's
actually going on I none of it has
anything to do with
oh I don't know camera angles or
anything like that it's just about
what's happening which is the basis of
all drama whether it's a screenplay or
or play how people inhabit a space at a
certain time that's it it seems almost
laughably simple or easy but it it
rarely makes it intact to a screen in
the way that that this has enhanced
greatly by the museum's sin and and and
the performances and everybody in every
department just working to preserve a
fundamental truth about a piece of
material your first draft how much
weight do you let it carry and then how
much time you know you talked about
giving time and space to actually
reading the story doing other things
trying to forget about it then coming
back what about with the first draft in
in what do you mean do I let it sit for
a while or how much weight do you
actually how much do you really obsess
over it or you just you know they called
the vomit draft and you cut yeah no I'm
not a vomit ER and mostly I think that
when scripts are not right fundamentally
in their first drafts they never will be
hence four five six writers being called
on to something in service of something
that wasn't right to begin with so you
should get a new take rather than try to
make put a band-aid on something that
doesn't work I wish more weight and more
time were given to first drafts because
they are often the draft that's closest
to something electric whether you're
writing a thriller or a quiet little
movie or a comedy and subsequent drafts
and however long someone works on
something in the end it always ends up
going back to
an earlier state when you've got the
right people working on something it's
always in my experience goes back to its
first fundamental state with
improvements of any of the scripts
you've written that maybe you haven't
put out into the world what do you feel
were the mistakes the initial mistakes
and how did you then go back and make
sure that never happened again well I
mean since I'm not really that writer
I'm too OCD to let anything awful get
out in the world I'm not so sure I've
made mistakes but what I think does
happen a fair amount is that you're
asked to do something that you're
fundamentally wrong for and so whatever
it is you put out there it could be the
best thing you've ever written it's not
going to be right for the people who
wanted some other fundamentally
different take so I think what I've
learned is to say no to things that I
know in my heart that I'm not good for
or believe me you don't want me you know
which is always a shock for people
because writers like the cliche of
writers is that they're needy and and
they're worried about always about the
next job and and I'm almost that person
who would rather not have the job than
do a bad job for someone not for me
because I can always find an interesting
take on something but if I know
i'ma tear a piece of source material and
I will only do adaptations for other
people I will not write original scripts
to give to other people because the
emotional investment is different
generally I just say no and it's the
best thing a screenwriter can learn to
do it will to preserve their own sanity
and also to make sure they do get other
jobs because then there's not a bunch of
people out there going oh that was awful